[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien schönen guten Abend
zusammen das sportliche Update über dem
Tor wieder Rudi Cerne sehr gerne schönen
guten Abend unter anderem diese Themen
haben wir heute für Sie vorbereitet
Ampel unter Druck auf der
Kabinettsklausur in Meseberg will die
Koalition wieder zu mehr Einigkeit
finden es geht auch um weitere
Entlastungen und die umstrittene
gasumlage
es wird noch teurer nach drei Monaten
läuft der Tankrabatt aus gleichzeitig
steigt die Inflation im August auf 7,9%
und Abschied aufgeschoben Tennisstar
Serena Williams gewinnt das Auftaktspiel
bei ihrem abschiedsturnier in New York
und wird für ihre Karriere gefeiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was wir alle beim Einkaufen schon lange
deutlich spüren gab es heute wieder
schwarz auf weiß die Inflationsrate
stieg im August auf knapp acht Prozent
dazu gleich mehr zunächst zum
kabinettstreffen auf Schloss Meseberg
neben Antworten auf die Krisen unserer
Zeit geht es auch um ampelharmonie statt
Einigkeit gab es zuletzt schließlich
Vorwürfe und deutliche kursunterschiede
Ines Trams das Wetter entspricht der
Stimmung die Tonlage hat sich verschärft
in der Ampel die SPD attackiert
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck die Grünen
greifen Kanzler Scholz an die FDP in den
Augen von SPD und Grünen ein Bremser
fast wie ein Appell ans eigene Team
klingen da Scholz Worte am Morgen
das wird eine Klausurtagung wo es gute
Stimmung gibt und die Bereitschaft in
einer ernsten Lage eng
zusammenzuarbeiten zum Wohl des Landes
die Tagesordnung reicht von einer
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie bis hin
zu Bildung doch tatsächlich drängend
eine Korrektur der umstrittenen
gasumlage Harbeck will nachbessern
ausschließen dass ich profitable
Unternehmen an der Umlage bereichern so
sollen nun nur Unternehmen unterstützt
werden die für die Gasversorgung
Deutschlands relevant sind und deren
Gasgeschäft für den Betrieb eine
bedeutsame Größe hat auch Boni dürften
diese Firmen nicht zahlen wir sind uns
sehr sicher dass wir schon mit diesen
Maßnahmen dafür Sorge tragen können dass
das was die deutsche Öffentlichkeit die
letzten vier fünf Tage so aufgewühlt hat
dann auch geklärt wird und diese
Unternehmen ihre Ansprüche wenn Sie die
dann noch aufrecht erhalten werden nicht
gewährt bekommen auch geht es um ein
drittes Entlastungspaket wie soll es
finanziert werden Spaniens
Ministerpräsident Gast bei der Klausur
red zur übergewinnsteuer die in Spanien
gilt Bundeskanzler ausweichend weiß er
doch der Koalitionspartner FDP will
diese Steuer nicht die Beratungen liefen
mehr sagt er nicht für den Prozess den
die Regierung sich vorgenommen hat gilt
dass wir das jetzt sehr ernsthaft sehr
intensiv und sehr vertraulich handhaben
auch deshalb weil wir schnell zu
Ergebnissen kommen wollen und es ja doch
eine Erfahrung ist das vertrauliche
Meinungsbildungsprozesse ihr Effizienz
haben auch in schweren Zeiten das
obligatorische Gruppenfoto auf Schloss
Meseberg im Laufe dieser Woche soll das
Entlastungspaket geschnürt werden so
heißt es hier
Klaus Brodbeck ist für uns vor Schloss
Meseberg Klaus große Krisentreffen auf
eine ampelregierung in der es zuletzt
ordentlich knirschte wie ist es denn um
die Atmosphäre in der Regierung bestellt
eine gemessen an dem was man die letzten
Tage aus der Ampelkoalition gehört hat
konnte es heute tatsächlich nur aufwärts
geht aber es scheint auch tatsächlich so
zu sein als dass man sich darum bemüht
wieder eine vernünftige
Arbeitsatmosphäre herzustellen dem
Appell des Kanzlers den wir eben im
Beitrag ja gehört haben schienen
jedenfalls alle Kabinettsmitglieder die
man heute so treffen konnte bei wenn sie
Statements gaben meistens in den drei
Farben der Koalition drei Vertreterinnen
schienen sehr bemüht immer darüber zu
reden wie gut man doch mit dem anderen
zusammenarbeitet wie gut man kooperiere
wie gut all dieses funktionieren mein
Eindruck ist dass diese Koalition
verstanden hat dass ihre
Rahmenbedingungen die
Unterschiedlichkeit der Partner und auch
die Weltlage schon genügend Probleme
machen und dass man mit dem
gegenseitigen behaken keine Punkte macht
mal sehen wie lange das hält Dankeschön
Klaus Brodbeck nach Schloss Meseberg ja
und dort geht es auch darum wie man der
rekordinflation begegnet mit Planung
gegen deswegen heute der Blick auf die
Veröffentlichung der aktuellen
Inflationsrate die weiter gestiegen ist
auf jetzt
7,9 Prozent und wir wollen das Einordnen
mit Valerie Haller in Frankfurt an der
Börse Valerie was bedeutet das für
Verbraucher und womit ist in den
nächsten Monaten zu rechnen zu rechnen
ist mit noch mehr Inflation zumal die
Teuerung im August ja schon höher war
als man eigentlich erwartet hatte ja und
das lässt erahnen was im Herbst auf uns
zukommt ökonomen rechnen mit einer
zweistelligen Inflationsrate die hohen
Preise belasten Verbraucher und
Unternehmen und damit steigt das Risiko
einer Rezession im Herbst erst im Laufe
des kommenden Jahres wird die Inflation
vermutlich wieder etwas nachlassen aber
höher bleiben als wir es lange lange
Zeit gewohnt waren Hauptprobleme sind
nach wie vor die hohen Preise für
Energie im August haben sie im Vergleich
zum Vorjahresmonat um über 35 Prozent
zugelegt auch Lebensmittel wurden
deutlich teurer über 16 Prozent die
hohen Preise an den Tankstellen die
prüft das Kartellamt ja schon eine ganze
Weile inzwischen hat es aber auch den
Lebensmittelhandel im visiermann
beobachtet die Preisentwicklung mit
Argusaugen hieß es heute von den
Wettbewerbshütern danke und Gruß nach
Frankfurt Valerie Haller also ein
Inflationstreiber war und ist der
Spritpreis und der dürfte Donnerstag
wieder steigen vorbei dann die Senkung
der Kraftstoffsteuer zu Entlastung von
Bürgern und Wirtschaft der Tankrabatt
endet als er im Juni eingeführt wurde da
ging es bei Super E10 und Diesel
tendenziell runter aber seit drei Wochen
muss an den Zapfsäulen wieder ständig
mehr gezahlt werden warum und überhaupt
kam vom Rabatt genug bei den Kunden an
dazu Dominik Müller Russell
heute in Düsseldorf schnell noch mal
tanken bevor die Preise deutlich
hochgehen
wenn die Preise wieder auf zwei Euro 20
steigen und dann noch die ganzen anderen
Kosten das ist natürlich schon heftig
man hat ja aus den anderen Ausgaben man
versucht das mitzunehmen was man kann
ich hoffe nicht dass das so extrem
steigen wird dass man sich das noch
einigermaßen leisten kann dass die
Preise schon kurz vor Auslaufen des
tankrabatts wieder anziehen habe mit
mehreren Kunden zu tun erklärt die
Mineralölbranche mit gestiegenen
Transportkosten etwa und Entwicklungen
auf dem Weltmarkt
einer beispielsweise ist das
Saudi-Arabien laut darüber nachdenkt die
Ölförderung zu drosseln um auf dem
Weltmarkt den Ölpreis zu erhöhen und das
hat schon Wirkung auf den Markt und hat
die Preise in den letzten Tagen erhöht
und Deutschland kann sich davon nicht
abkoppeln den Tankrabatt habe man
komplett weitergegeben deshalb werde man
auch nun den Anstieg der Energiesteuer
auf das alte Level weitergeben 35 Cent
mehr pro Liter Benzin und 17 Cent mehr
pro Liter Diesel doch Kritiker halten
die Argumente mit denen die Branche ihre
letzten Preisanstiege begründet
teilweise für vorgeschoben das ist aus
unserer Sicht nicht gerechtfertigt
sondern hier versuchen die Konzerne
wieder ein Stück weit ein Puffer sich in
die eigene Tasche zu stecken die Preise
werden weiter steigen und zwar deutlich
zum ersten September wenn der Tankrabatt
ausläuft so viel ist sicher
ja wie unabhängiger werden von fossiler
Energie aus Russland darüber haben heute
die acht Ostsee Anrainerstaaten der EU
darunter auch Deutschland beraten
geeinigt haben sich die Staats- und
Regierungschefs auf einen massiven
Ausbau der Windkraftanlagen auf dem Meer
so soll die offshore windkapazität bis
2030 Vers 7 facht werden
aus dem Süden der Ukraine werden wieder
schwere Kämpfe gemeldet dort gibt es
wohl eine ukrainische Großoffensive
allerdings nur spärliche Informationen
an mehreren Stellen der Frontlinie
entlang der Provinz Carson versucht das
ukrainische Militär weiter vorzurücken
Lena sünderbruch
vor sechs Monaten hätte das
Schussgeräusch André vielleicht
aufgeschreckt er ist eigentlich
Ingenieur war nach Westeuropa gezogen
doch der russische Angriff hat ihn aus
seinem zivilen Leben gerissen er ist
freiwillig als Scharfschütze in die
Ukraine zurückgekehrt deren Streitkräfte
haben nach eigenen Angaben eine
Gegenoffensive auf Russisch besetzte
Gebiete gestartet sie wollen die Gegend
um die Stadt herson zurückerobern in den
vergangenen Wochen hatte die Ukraine
dort vorbereiten bereits alle großen
Brücken zerstört die die russischen
Truppen für ihren Nachschub nutzten nun
hat die Ukraine ihr Artilleriefeuer auf
herrsson verstärkt und meldet Erfolge
Russland dementiert laut
militär-experten lässt sich die Lage
nach wie vor sehr schwer einschätzen
generell ist es so dass die Ukraine
nicht viel mehr oder überhaupt nicht
mehr Kräfte in diesem Raum haben als die
Russen das heißt ein Angriff der den
Durchbruch erzwingen
will oder der geht sich schwer aus der
ukrainische Präsident selenski macht nur
Andeutungen zum mutmaßlichen Offensive
die Besatzer müssen wissen wir werden
sie bis zur Grenze jagen wenn sie
überleben wollen ist es für das
russische Militär an der Zeit abzuhauen
geht nach Hause Scharfschütze Andri war
schon beim erbitterten Kampf um Kiew
dabei er töte nicht gern sagt er doch er
will schon bald in den nächsten Einsatz
ziehen dieses Mal vielleicht in reison
wenn es darum geht der Ukraine
militärisch weiter unter die Arme zu
greifen will die EU künftig stärker an
einem Strang ziehen bei ihrem Treffen in
Prag hatten die Verteidigungsminister
der Mitgliedstaaten dabei besonders die
Ausbildung ukrainischer Soldaten im
Blick geprüft werden soll jetzt ob die
EU die Koordination bei der Ausbildung
übernehmen kann Florian neuhahn
berichtet ohne Training bringt die
modernste Waffe nichts an diesem
Flugabwehr kanonenpanzern etwa bildet
die Bundeswehr ukrainische Soldaten aus
wäre das nicht auch unter Führung der
eu-denkbar fragt sich der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Giuseppe sich auf
eine solche ausbildungsmission im
Grundsatz zu einigen ist für die
eu-verteidigungsminister am Vormittag in
Prag noch leicht
wir müssen die Grundlage legen für eine
Armee die noch für eine lange Zeit wird
kämpfen müssen
am Nachmittag dann reisen die
EU-Außenminister an und mit ihnen ein
Konflikt der die Regierungen tief
spaltet soll ganz Europa russischen
Touristen Visa verweigern wie es etwa
baltische Staaten schon tun
diese schweigsamen Privatpersonen müssen
verstehen dass dieser Krieg Konsequenzen
hat von ihren Steuergeldern werden die
Bomben bezahlt die im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes in diesem Moment ukrainische
Kinder töten
children andere allen voran die
französische Außenministerin und die
deutsche fürchten dadurch letzte
Verbindungen zu kappen auch zu
Oppositionellen dieser Bundesregierung
ist wichtig das was uns auch ermöglicht
hat sehr schnell verfolgten Menschen in
Russland eine rausreise zu ermöglichen
dass wir das uns nicht nehmen denkbar
wäre nun die Hürden für die Visa-Vergabe
an Russen deutlich zu erhöhen zumindest
in einem ersten Schritt
schauen wir jetzt in den Krisen
geschüttelten Irak dort schlägt das
politische Vakuum in Gewalt um und er
steht im Mittelpunkt der Schiitenführer
mukada als sadre vor zehn Monaten hatte
als satis-partei die meisten Sitze bei
der Parlamentswahl gewonnen eine
Regierung gibt es bis heute trotzdem
nicht als Sattel weigert sich mit einer
pro iranischen schiitischen
parteien-allianz zu regieren die
gestrige Ankündigung seines Rückzugs
löste schwere Krawalle aus zur Situation
im Irak golini Atay
Rückzug auf Zeit
hunderte Männer aus dem ärmsten Gegenden
buckets stellen ihre Angriffe vorerst
ein
einen ganzen Tag kämpften irakskiiten
gegeneinander die einen unterstützt vom
Nachbarn Iran die anderen Wahlsieger des
vergangenen Jahres aber immer noch ohne
Regierungsmacht
ihr hält und Anführer Mutter
geistlicher aus einer Familie
schiitischer Gelehrter er präsentiert
sich als Reformer gegen Korruption und
will seine Macht nicht mit Pro
iranischen Gruppen teilen nach
gescheiterten Verhandlungen zur
Regierungsbildung verkündete gestern
seinen Rückzug
daraufhin strömten seine Getreuen ins
Regierungsviertel stürmten Gebäude und
forderten mit Waffengewalt Reformen und
einen Neuanfang des politischen Systems
eine Machtdemonstration bisasada die
Gewalt seiner Anhänger scharf
verurteilte
ich hatte auch friedliche Proteste
gehofft Proteste von Menschen die ihr
Land lieben nicht Menschen die zu
schweren Waffen greifen
die meisten Iraker stehen zwischen den
Fronten
wir haben die ganze Lage satt ich glaube
nicht dass ich irgendetwas besser wird
das alles wird sich negativ aus auf
unsere Wirtschaft auf unsere Jugend die
wir dadurch in falsche Bahnen gelenkt
weil es keine Arbeitsplätze für Sie gibt
die Angst vieler hier dass ihr Land vor
einem neuen Bürgerkrieg stehen könnte
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Özdemir
wird mit dem Leo Beck Preis geehrt er
ist die höchste Auszeichnung des
Zentralrates der Juden in Deutschland
öste mir engagiere sich seit Jahren für
ein liberales und aufgeklärtes
Deutschland und gegen Antisemitismus
hieß es zu Begründung die
Preisverleihung soll im Oktober
stattfinden
Wälder gingen in Flammen auf Flüsse und
Felder trockneten aus und dafür gab es
so viel Sonne wie nie ganz klar die
Auswirkungen der Klimaerwärmung sagen
die allermeisten Experten die
Zwischenbilanz des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes heute untermauert ist mit
817 Stunden Sonnenschein war es der
sonnenreichste Sommer seit Aufzeichnung
statt und es war wieder sehr trocken
rund 145 Liter Regen vielen pro
Quadratmeter 40% weniger Niederschlag
als in der Vergleichsperiode zwischen
1961 und 1990 Peter Wagner
der Rhein nicht nur als Wasserstraße von
erheblicher Bedeutung hier in Biebesheim
werden täglich 130 Millionen Liter
abgepumpt bei extremem niedrigpegel nur
die Hälfte und dem Wasserwerk aufwendig
gereinigt anschließend versickert es in
solchen Gräben füllt die
Grundwasserschichten im Hessischen Ried
wie einen Schwamm wieder auf daraus wird
neues Trinkwasser ein Modell das Schule
machen könnte
speichern das
Wasser eine
Möglichkeit in großen Teilen
Deutschlands war der Sommer viel zu
trocken das Saarland Rheinland-Pfalz und
Hessen melden eine historische
Sommerdürre das macht der Landwirtschaft
zu schaffen setzt den ohnehin
Geschädigten Wäldern weiter zu ein
Problem das sich seit 2013 dramatisch
verschärft dunkelrot bis violett sind
die alarmfarben im dürre-monitor des
helmholtz-
wir hatten wirklich viele extreme erlebt
neue hitzere gerade in Norddeutschland
Sonnenschein Rekord in Deutschland in
vielen Regionen sogar der trockenste
Sommer seit Messbeginn also so viel
Rekorde in einem Sommer habe ich als
metrologe noch nicht erlebt der heißeste
Ort liegt übrigens im vermeintlich
kühlen Norden Hamburg meldet am 20 Juli
40,1°c richtig viel Regen gab es im
Voralpenland 500 Liter seit Juni
manchmal in extrem kurzer Zeit
ja jetzt weiter mit dem Sport und Rudi
Cerne DFB-Pokal Teil 2
Runde bei uns im ZDF nachher FC Teutonia
Ottensen gegen Pokalverteidiger RB
Leipzig die Favoritenrolle liegt klar
bei den Leipzigern die es mit einem
viertlisten zu tun haben im größten
Spiel der Vereinsgeschichte will man so
ist zu hören nicht einfach den Bus vor
dem eigenen 16er parken und nur
verteidigen
Jochen Breyer in Leipzig zu diesem Spiel
gibt es ja eine kuriose Vorgeschichte ne
ja Rudi das waren Iris hin und her
Teutonia ist ja Viertligist hätte
eigentlich Heimrecht gehabt aber
Ottensen hat nur einen Kunstrasenplatz
darauf darf im Pokal nicht gespielt
werden deshalb wollte man zum FC St
Pauli in Hamburg ausreichen St Pauli hat
das wiederum abgelehnt weil man dem
Konstrukt RB Leipzig und dessen
Hauptsponsor dem Geldgeber einem
brausekonzern keine Bühne bieten wollte
so dann wollte man nach Dessau gehen
dort gab es einen Anschlag auf den Rasen
die Bilder sehen wir hier noch mal also
der Rasen war dann unbespielbar
unbekannter hatten da ein Gift
ausgeschüttet so und so ist man also
also wahrscheinlich auch eine
Protestaktion gegen RB Leipzig und so
ist man also hier in Leipzig gelandet RB
sollte geschadet werden hat dadurch am
Ende ein Heimspiel gewonnen aber
Teutonia Ottensen träumt natürlich
trotzdem von der Sensation wir melden
uns um 20:15 Uhr hier aus Leipzig vielen
Dank Jochen und bis nachher
zum Tennis Serena Williams steht in der
zweiten Runde der US Open die
langjährige Weltranglisten erste
besiegte Danker kovinic aus Montenegro
in zwei Sätzen und erlebte einen
emotionalen Abend
für die 23 malige Grand Slam
turnier-siegerin ist es ein
triumphfahrer und sehr bewegender
Auftritt im Stadium auf dem Platz und
auch daneben Show Musik und Politgrößen
wollen Serena Williams noch einmal live
erleben und sie gibt Kostproben ihres
außergewöhnlichen Könnens womit sie
schon immer die Massen begeisterte so
auch bei ihrem erst runden Match ihrer
letzten US Open 40 Jahre alt ist sie
inzwischen aber frischer schneller und
überzeugender als Danker kovinic die
montenegrinerin ist 13 Jahre jünger und
chancenlos glatt in zwei Sätzen gewinnt
Williams und genießt anschließend eine
überwältigende we love Serena Show
eine richtige tennisgala Laura Siegemund
ist als zweite deutsche Tennisspielerin
bei den US Open ausgeschieden die
34-Jährige aus Metzingen unterlag der
Rumänien Zorana kirstea glatt in zwei
Sätzen mit 4 zu 46 im zweiten Durchgang
hatte Siegemund noch vier zu zwei in
Führung gelegen hatte dann aber den
Druck von den Spiel der Rumänen nichts
mehr entgegenzusetzen
schönes Tennis heute danke schön und wir
sagen Ihnen das von Südwesten
gewittriger Regen aufzieht wie weit der
nach Norden vorankommt dass erläutert
gleich Katja horneffer ich empfehle das
heute schon mal mit Christian Sievers in
der Fußballpause gegen 21 Uhr das
gesamte heute 19 Team sagt danke fürs
zuschauen wünscht einen schönen Abend
und freut sich auch morgen auf Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend von Südwesten kommt jetzt
gewittriger Starkregen das ist in diesem
Dürrezeiten ja eigentlich eine gute
Nachricht wobei die Region die den Regen
besonders dringend nötig hätten hier im
Westen und im Nordwesten wohl wieder
leer ausgeht dort ist es heute Nacht nur
locker bewölkt und die Temperaturen
sinken auch Werte von 17 Grad am
Oberrhein und acht Grad hier in der Nähe
von Hamburg der gewittrige Starkregen
zieht morgen über Tag entlang der alten
weiter ostwärts dann verdüstern sich
auch die Wolken hier im Bayerischen Wald
nachmittags lockern die Wolken am
Oberrhein aber schon wieder auf und
nördlich von Eifel Westerwald Rhön
Thüringer Wald und Erzgebirge wird das
morgen ein freundlicher Tag zum Teil
sogar richtig sonnig in
Schleswig-Holstein bei Nordostwind
liegen die Temperaturen an der Ostsee
bei 19 Grad 17 Grad sind es im
Dauerregen am Alpenrand 26 Grad werden
es am Donnerstag kann es dann in Bayern
noch etwas regnen am Freitag kommen neue
Gewitter von Südwesten heran und die
weiten sich dann am Samstag weiter aus
nur der Norden bleibt davon dann noch
verschont guten Abend